ARE UNDERWAY.
CYCLED TO JEFF CARTER.
BACK UP TOP.
WE SAW WRIST
RODRIGUES.
HE HITS THE IRON.
AHEAD OF LARS ELLER.
RODRIGUES  HAD A TERRIFIC  DOWN
WRIST SHOT.
SAFE MADE BY SAMSONON
'S WRISTER IS CLUBBED DOWN BY
MOVE UP.
>> TEDDY BLUEGER, ONE TOUCH TH
IS NOT JUST LUCK.
OVECHKIN JUST MISSED
>> Ray: WASHINGTON'S BEST
CHANCE HAS COME AMONGST A THROU
TRAFFIC IN FRONT OF HIM.
HE'S A LITTLE LALA
TOE DRAG.
MOVES IN PULLS THE PUCK INTO
THE PADS OF
WE BEGIN.
CONOR SHEARY WAS NOT THE PUCK O
IT.ILYA SAMSONOV.
, BROCK McGINN WHO BY AND
KAPANEN ALL COMBINED TO STRIKE
OUTSTANDING TONIGHT.
A COUPLE OF CHANCES IN THE
FIRST.. NOW LEASON LETANG.
KAPANEN.
POWER, SPEED.
HERE HE FINDS DOMINIK SIMON.
STRIKE
ARE IN NO POSITION TO DENY HIM.
HE SLIDES IT ON THE LEFT FOOT K
UNBELIEVABLE SAVE.
SPRAWLING TO HIS RIGHT, SAMSONOV
AS LEANING TO HIS RIGHT.
THEN HE FLASHES THE LEFT PADAD
IT'S NOT OVER YET.
OVECHKIN TO ELLER.
ICE. UICK SEVER PASSER
OVECHKIN HAS HIS SECOND ASSIST
OF THE NIGHT AND LARS ELLER
MAKES A PERFECT WITH 1:53 TO
GO, THE PENGUINS HAVE A TWO
THEN RAY SAID THE EXTRA BAD
BREAK AS IT HITS THE LEGS OF